[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to the
floating steampunk island nation or fall
Farah today's episode is kind of split
into two separate parts sort of not that
much but I'm beginning with a bunch of
random bits and bobs alongside the
island pretty much like I've been doing
all this time just adding a bit of
scenery here and there then halfway
through the video there's a bit of a
section on a dark right part of the ride
it's quite an extensive section actually
mostly because of some lighting changes
that I'll go into in a minute and the
very last part of this video and really
what I wanted to name this video after
because it's actually been one of my
favorite things from this episode and
definitely one of my favorite things to
work on is the big golden domes which
are replacing some of the older domes
and spires that I did have in place but
that were made using older pieces in
that I think at this point look kind of
outdated and so I'm just dragging in the
new pieces mostly from the adventure
updates to try and give the whole island
a bit of a slightly updated look add
some extra colors in there make
everything look a little bit less to
wrap because I think you know even
though it's steampunk all of the
textures at the moment are very greyish
very dark and there's not much shiny
going on and now that we have those new
adventure pieces with those supposedly
gold pieces I think there's a bunch of
stuff in there that we can actually use
to create a brassy look for some of the
elements of the castle so yeah we'll go
into that at a later stage right now
though I the thoughts that I wanted to
get some more foliage onto this island
and this has always been one of those
things that for me felt like a really
difficult decision to make because it's
a steampunk theme and it's a really
industrial theme and I'm trying to make
the island as gritty and as detailed as
possible but I really felt like it would
look a little bit better with just a tad
of foliage not too much but just a few
trees here and there so literally what I
did is I just plopped a bunch of trees
in the air
wherever I felt like it would look good
to have a tree and then afterwards I
basically worried at a later stage how I
could actually realistically connect
these trees to the island and sort of
give them a planter to stand in so
structurally they really don't make much
sense at all I just wanted to figure out
what places would look slightly better
with the tree and just kind of get that
as a limitation to work around and come
up with some creative solutions to
basically have floating trees more or
less in certain places so there's this
big wide open space in the middle of the
right where a lots of lots of tracks are
crossing over each other and there's
lots of bridges and pipes and I just put
a tree up in there because it it was a
bit too gritty and industrial with a
lack of colors that I felt like some
greenery would fit right in there and
then there's a few trees alongside the
outskirts of the island where I felt it
would be nice to have some things poking
out and having a tree somewhere would be
a pretty good reason to build like one
of these basically these kinds of
balcony ish sections and yeah they
definitely don't make much sense but
then again this is a flying castle and
what really makes sense involve ah I
just thought it would be a neat idea to
add some foliage into the castle and I
can see why for some people maybe this
might seem like something that goes more
or less against the theme and the island
might might look a little bit better
without all of this foliage but in my
opinion I think it looks just a bit
better by adding this foliage to it
without it it's just a lot of the same
colors and I didn't want to adjust the
color scheme too much because I didn't
want everything to be all of these
industry or gritty brownish colors but
at the same time I did want to add a bit
more vibrant look to this island and I
think I think foliage is probably the
best way to go around doing that there's
also some slightly minor ways of adding
some foliage here and there as well
obviously lots of planters and small
window boxes with those flowers so
there's lots of that smaller stuff as
well
but yeah that's mostly when I'm starting
off this episode with and if there is
anything that I could say about foliage
regarding that please definitely kind of
recognizable in a sense that I do often
spend a lot of time just moving a few
trees around honestly when you're
looking at a very very large facade or
your weenie perhaps or a Main Street or
some major sites I think three
placements is like one of those very
minor details that I always end up
spending a lot of time just to kind of
figure out where exactly I want to see
the tree where exactly I wanted to be
placed what kind of tree I'm looking for
and honestly sometimes I spend more time
placing just a few trees around a really
important building in a way that adds to
the building rather than blocks the view
of it then I would spend building an
entire forest just because for me it's
it's always so important to like get the
placement exactly right and honestly I'm
just a fan of seeing some well-placed
foliage I think in some places it can be
it can be very good if you just spend a
lot of time thinking very critically
about where you want to put your tree
and that was one of the most ridiculous
sentences I've ever set on video but I'm
pretty serious with this it just kind of
depends on on how much of an impact the
tree is gonna have if it's in the middle
of the street or around a weenie or
something like that I think it's quite
important but if it's further away if
it's with less detail or if it's just in
a forest in that case I don't think you
should be too concerned about your trees
and just pretty much plop them down
wherever as quickly as possible it just
kind of depends on the context I suppose
in any case that is that is everything
about foliage on this floating castle
for now I wanted to get into the
lighting and actually discuss what I
said I would discuss at the beginning of
this video because there's been a
lighting change in recent planet coaster
updates and honestly I don't actually
even remember which update it was
whether it was the adventure update or
the studio spec updates so I honestly
didn't ever notice this before I guess
it's just because I don't have a
right that interacts with terraforming
the way that this one does plus I just
haven't played planet coaster that much
recently but I just looked at vara
recently and found out that it's a lot
darker inside than it used to be
so before I started this time-lapse I
just did a bunch of off ride or
off-screen stuff where I tried placing
as much terraforming as I could
inside the castle walls without being
visible because now with the new
lighting terraforming really blocks the
lights even if it's just a very narrow
layer of ground in the past that
wouldn't really block the light too much
and it was still kind of shine through
but nowadays it pretty much makes it
almost pitch black underneath it and
while there's been some criticisms
against this I know that a lot of people
have been complaining that it's too dark
in caves or underneath rock formations
in the case of for vara it's actually
pretty much perfect because I've always
wanted the inside part of this castle to
be as dark as I could to really feel
like a dark right section it was just
always kind of impossible because this
castle is so compact there's barely any
space for terraforming to create this
kind of light but with the new lighting
system I can basically hide a very
narrow layer of terraforming inside the
dome alongside the edges of the dome in
some of these walls as well so that it's
pretty much dark inside of here even
though the walls are pretty thin so I'm
actually really glad with that change
think for one it makes the ride a little
bit more interesting because you're sort
of flying in and out with the lights
you've got those outside sections where
obviously it's really bright and you've
got all the foliage and stuff but you
keep flying through the building itself
as well so lots of interesting contrasts
there and I also think it just looks a
little bit better if you're looking at
the castle from an outside perspective
as well like you can see some of the
entrances that the coaster track is
going into the building with and you can
really see it going through a dark
tunnel you can really see it entering
pitch black resin the in the past the
insides of buildings just kind of looked
like shadowy the whole thing we just
have the colour of a shadow but it won't
actually never
be dark and the fact that it's really
actually dark now is pretty awesome at
least for this project so yeah I'm
really glad with how dark this new
lighting is and kind of hoping that
things are gonna stay this way but we'll
see about that in any case for now I've
decided to work on the dark ride section
and provide some lighting over here I'm
not going to finish it yet I'm actually
gonna dedicate the next episode to that
because there's still some other things
that I wanted to do over here but at
least the foundation is pretty much here
also decided to do a little bit of work
on the station itself and I suppose this
is where you can see some of the
limitations coming in of this this new
lighting change because the way that it
works is that walls still don't block
lights they only cost shadows so with
walls alone you're not gonna achieve
this effect it's only terraforming and
it's only underneath the terraforming
that you're gonna get this dark color so
if the entrance is into the building
were really large the the like
difference in lights would feel really
unnatural you would just kind of have
like one place would be completely dark
and then right next to it would be
completely light and it wouldn't really
make sense if you look at it from the
outside so I tried making the entrances
into the building as narrow as possible
so that the entrances look like they're
really blocking off all the lights and
then that's the reason that all of a
sudden it gets really dark really
quickly as you're entering the building
and leaving their building so yeah that
just kind of helps sell the illusion a
little bit better than all the walls are
actually what what is making it so dark
inside even though it's really the the
terraforming so yeah that's a little bit
of that dark ride stuff but we'll get
back to that later in the future for now
I I think I just didn't have my fix of
spires in too long because I just
couldn't stop myself from stopping
whenever I was working on and working on
some spires now I'm gonna attempt a
spire which I've never tried before and
it's a little bit of an annoying spire
to do it's a combination between that
spiral spire that
had earlier in this series and first
episode actually and a onion spire so
it's it's a bit of an annoying shape to
work with but it's surprisingly easy to
make it just went through a couple of
different iterations of it until at some
point I decided that just making it a
simple spire with a simple spiral
pattern would be enough but at this
point I was still kind of using the idea
of having two spires within one spire I
guess like that that old meme where it's
like hey I see you like spires so I
could aspire in your spire so you can
can get inspired or something I don't
know anyway that that idea of stitched
eventually because that just kind of
looked ridiculous even though I do kind
of dig the look of it I don't think it
quite fits with the rest of the of the
castle so yeah it had a bit of a strange
look so eventually I ditched that idea
and did something else for a while I was
also thinking you know what I could try
that word again but then I realized that
we should totally get some bronze colors
in here and the brassy looks pretty damn
good if you get some light colors so at
this point I just got the scenery items
which you're supposed to build like
fountains and statues with but which
actually work really well for doing
these kinds of it's almost art piece
sculptures but then with the gold
texture I've got a couple of questions
already on how I did this fire well this
is basically how just a variety of
supposed statue pieces I believe they
should be just kind of laid down as if
they were these separate bricks of like
brass roof tiles that are all put
together to form this spiral roof also
importantly the wooden frame of the roof
is on a different building then the
actual brass is just to make things a
little bit easier to like change the
colors later on or change the design
ever so slightly I think sometimes if
you're doing complicated spires like
this it can really help too
separate your framework from whatever
you're using to make the roof itself
just so that if you want to recolor
stuff for that kind of thing later on
you can do so just by hovering over the
entire thing instead of having to select
every single piece separately which we
take way too long
see yeah that's one spider down and a
few more to go I believe if I remember
correctly that's three more to go so
that was the spire which still had an
in-game roof piece and you know me I
don't mess with in-game pieces that had
to be gone at some point so it's it's
finally time to get rid of that thing
replace it with a I would always say
slightly better custom version I don't
know if it's slightly better but at
least it's different
and that's what I was going for at least
it has a brassy texture that looks
pretty neat so this is just a simple
spire quote-unquote that just has a very
similar shape to what the in-game roof
has just with a different texture just
because I like the way that the tower
looked previously I just wasn't really
digging this simple roofed exterior and
the fact that it looks like every single
roof ever so I just made that quick
section then rotate it is and rotated it
as you normally do actually made a
mistake with the rotation I rotated it a
little bit too much and then I realized
that it actually looks like brass roof
tiles now so that was a bit of an
accident and I decided to kill me keep
that in because it actually looks pretty
damn awesome it gives a lot of detail to
that spire and makes for a really
interesting texture I guess the only
downside is it uses a lot of pieces but
honestly this island is already on so
many pieces that I really can't be
bothered too much about that sort of
thing so moving on we've already been at
the dome for a while I didn't want to
place the entire dome that would have
been really annoying to do and also I
think that would be better to be red I
still want red to be the main color of
the roofs and gold to be more of a brass
color to be more of an accent color so
it's used on a few towers it's used in
some parts of the castle but it's more
of an accent then
Rufe there's a sort of very basic rule
of thumb and I'm already starting on a
new town where don't worry I'll get to
that at some point but there's this sort
of basic rule of thumb in Main Street
buildings but I think it can count for a
lot of buildings if you want to play it
safe to just choose three different
colors choose one color for your roof
choose one color for your walls and
choose a color for your accents and the
action and the accents could be a small
cupola on the roof it could be the the
windows it could be a small cover over
the over the front door just any small
parts the wall colors just have to be
one certain color with maybe some slight
variation and then you choose your roof
color and there's a bit of a bit of an
idea of that in the entire island as
well the general wall color is that that
beige brick ish texture the sort of
default roof color is red and then for
the excellence there is gold and some
green here and there as well because I
did want to have slightly more variation
than just choosing warm colors
everywhere so yeah I finished that other
spire and now it is time for a very fun
little project as soon as I'm done with
just a final finishing touches of this
little guy here where I wanted to try
and make a very small pavilion but
apparently I'm still spending a lot of
time trying to figure this thing out in
the end um that's not too interesting
anyway let's get to the pavilion come on
there we go
so this is a a place where I always
wondered what I could do with it because
looking at the castle I always felt like
there was a tower missing over here but
it wouldn't really make sense to have a
tower at this base because they're sort
of this very this this outdoor plaza
that's coming out of the taller parts of
the building and I definitely wanted to
keep the entire roof here flat and not
build like crazy spires or something and
I figured I might as well just build a
pavilion on this place which isn't so
much part of the building architecture
Lee but just kind of plopped on top of
it and I thought that would be a pretty
interesting way to get around it also
means that there's a
bit of variety like it's not just towers
there's a there's a pure domes as well
and then you've got this neat little
pavilion and honestly I don't think I've
ever tried my hand at a victorian-esque
pavilion in this game before and I'm a
huge fan of those things I think they
look really cool with those those narrow
pillars all of that detailing and like
these roofs which really stick out from
the pillars as well just in general
they're pretty awesome stuff like that
that little Pavilion in Disney's main
streets that's the the sort of thing
that this was inspired by so working on
the pavilion foundation itself is not
too difficult just gonna put a post in
the middle and then kind of work your
way around that my general rule of thumb
is whatever you were building outward
from that post just make sure that the
end of that is parallel with the post if
you're looking at the post from straight
ahead so you can see me looking at the
post a few times just to make sure that
this little triangular thing that I'm
building outside the post is actually
gonna line up correctly when I copy this
all over with that whole circular method
of making spires so that means it can
splay save a whole lot of time you just
make one small triangular parts of the
pavilion and should hook up correctly
sorry I was out of it for a second my
sister just came home but yeah that is
really basically the the general
strategy for this little between here
one thing that sort of separates it from
what it's inspired by is that usually
these pavilions tend to have more of a
flat roof I suppose something like a
dome like roof or a roof that does point
upward at the start but sort of turns
into a dome at the top and this one is
really much more like a spire it's much
more vertical it goes up quite some
Heights I think actually it's taller
than the the lower floors of this thing
including the spire so it's it's a
pretty tall little thing but that's just
kind of what I wanted to do with this
thing I felt like there was a spire like
shape missing in the middle of the
castle and hopefully this is a good way
to
that kind of thing without having to add
another tower it's also interesting how
now I'm using completely different
things to finish off the spires like
these new adventure pieces think you can
kind of tell it through the way that I'm
making the spires that the game has
changed a lot over the years especially
because I've been making this Park for
more than a year already so you can
definitely see these differences within
this park already anyway don't don't
play drinking games with the word spire
in this episode that's it thank you guys
for watching and I'll see you guys in
the next episode
[Music]